hello everybody we had a lot of exciting
openings today we definitely had some
action in the Aronian game we have
really good preparation by a non but I
want to take a look at how the game
started in two games today we're going
to take a look at the open Sicilian
which is a favorite not only of gin but
of many chess players that many
grandmasters around the world and i'm
going to explain a little bit why so
first of all i want to take a look at
this game this is how the game between
Christian and Apollo started today and
here black play the move a six now when
I talk to my students and I tell them
how do you learn in your opening what do
you need to do the first thing that I
meet them to understand is why you're
making moves and I know a lot of people
that are strong and sometimes not so
strong that they want to play the night
or because the top players played the
pile of place in a Kimura place like a
spiral plated Fisher belated but they
can't tell me what the movie 6 is for so
we're going to analyze the position
right now and determine in the structure
what black wants to do and very commonly
in this structure black wants to play
the movie 5v5 is a good move because it
gains a temple it forces the night out
of the center it allows the bishop to
come to e7 and it gains some space in
the center ok you can't ask for much
more from a move however the phone with
e 5 in this position is that it weakens
the d5 square not only that in this
particular position after Bishop b5
check there isn't a good way of covering
this check if I play Bishop d7 then my
light squares are further weakened so
that's not a good idea but 97 also
blocks the control of the bishop of 95
and then I can go to f5 attacking this
spawn therefore in this position Black
has resorted to play a 6 first note with
the idea of playing be five anytime soon
because it doesn't really help his
development but to push the pawn to e5
and scare the night away interestingly
White has pretty much tried everything
under the Sun in this position and it's
still unclear to this day what path you
should choose back in the day Fisher try
to play Bishop c4 and also the move
Bishop c5
to be very popular a couple of decades
ago these moves were aimed against the
movie 5 notice how they both control d5
either directly or indirectly the bishop
on c4 has a strong diagonal with an
attack on or seven so black usually
replies with e6 whereas with Bishop g5
you're already pinning this night that
depends on d5 so also hear you five is
no good but pretty much against any
other move and white has tried several
they've tried a four they've tried f4
which is known as the carpet variation
they've tried Bishop e3 known as the
English tactics Friedrich g'wan they've
tried h3 literally every move has been
tried in this position and it's still
unclear what to do this is a game that's
been in fashion since the 9th or four
started we saw the pilot play the move
f3 one of the sharpest approaches to the
position and of course we've got a very
sharp knife between those two players
now very different difficult to
understand kind of position is this
fashion Acosta ceiling which was the one
that caused and chose today and it's
impossible to talk about this fashion
gov without mentioning fashion this
version cuff is a fashionable opening
sometimes and then sometimes everybody
stops playing it it goes through periods
where a lot of Grand Masters played and
sometimes just nobody does at the moment
only Gelfand really plays the special
golf at the top level but it's nice to
see that the world champion is using it
yet again now the difference between 'if
I've in the other position and with d6
and here with the knight on c6 is that
of course there's no Bishop b5 Jack
however for a long time this opening was
considered to be in figure 4 black
because I'm through the move 9 db5
threatening 96 Chuck forcing d6 Bishop
g5 a 693 be five most people thought
that after Bishop f6 Black has to
recapture with the phone that they were
simply too many weaknesses for black to
deal with and this is a thought that was
true for most of the 80s even part of
the 90s but then very strong Grandmaster
started playing this and discovering
that the flexibility of the pawn
structure was worth much much more than
the weaknesses that they have right now
the possibility of breaking with a five
the awkward positioning of this night on
a three were more than sufficient
compensation therefore lately we have a
little bit of more positional approach
in this position instead of taking one
of six directly white first puts the
knight on d5 forcing Bishop e7 and only
then takes on f6 which is the game that
we're looking at today between geary and
carlsen very different types of
Sicilians even though they're both open
Sicilians but one definitely very very
risky and the other one a little bit
more positional it's interesting to see
how openings shape up and how fashion
shapes them in completely different
styles so even though the Sicilian is
supposed to be a very sharp opening we
can see that it transforms itself into
many many things